are you single now I'm single now okay
what do you look for in a lady someone
that can put over my dog no she's only a
girl in my life right now sir
[Music]
hello happy Friday welcome back to
certified country I'm Sophie she lacy
joining me today is Michael ray thank
you for being here so the new single is
get to you tell me about why that song
is so special to you um well it's the
first song of my second album which is a
very important record and we were very
lucky to have a couple number ones off
the first one so special in that aspect
but it's also special to me because I
think they're in the middle of recording
a song I was going through word for
where what this song was saying
[Music]
and so being a studio and singing those
lyrics and really living him at the same
time was was pretty special and honestly
therapeutic for me so it's it's a
special song for me are you single now
I'm single now okay what do you look for
in a lady someone that could put over my
dog no she's only a girl in my life
right now so that's true love and having
a pop that's all right my dog is a husky
Shepherd mix her name is Wrigley we were
playing this place called this event
called Lake shake I was gonna do this
thing with the paws rescue organization
there and I was just like man I got it I
gotta take her so I adopt her that night
and she got on the bus and has been with
me ever since and and why start posting
photos with her faith started bringing
toys and treats and all this stuff but
they're bringing them by like the bag I
was leaving a weekend with like 30 40
toys I was just like giving it to my
band I was like I didn't know I was like
I'm raising a spoiled daughter I don't
know what to do can we go into these
towns these cities they open up every
door they were all the red carpet we
shop local we try to get the local
coffee try to you know local brewery or
whatever it may be I was like how can i
how can we give back and what some
that's close to me and it means a lot to
me and one day we just came up with the
idea of well if they're kind of fans
we'll bring this for Reglan
how can we make awareness in their
cities about their rescues and so we
started a foundation called Wrigley
cares
under under Wrigley and partner with
Zappos for good who helped us find local
shelters in the in the communities that
we were going to play on the get to tour
and we'd set this bin and we invited the
shelter and we asked fans hey bring dog
food cat food blankets tree you know
toys whatever you can bring and we're
gonna donate it to the local animal
rescue in local city next thing I know
guys bringing a pallet of dog food do
people are bringing truckloads ladies
are getting together and they're making
those non stitch blankets or whatever
they're calling by 30 or 40 of them and
I mean the bins overflowing and they say
you know we've fed over 150,000 meals in
a month and a half and has continued to
grow and so you know Wrigley came into
my life at a special time and helped me
get through some hard times and and she
just completely changed my life and now
we have this this great organization
that we have a foundation that we have a
thanks to the fans for for helping us
connect and build something like this
and help where is awareness for
and headed off no how are you as a dog
dad no she's she's she is definitely
spoiled you sure she's ever if it not
enough by me the fans are there to pick
up any slack I might have left on the
spoiling side of things thank you guys
so much for watching if this is your
first time with us be sure to subscribe
to entertainment tonight on YouTube we
will be back again with a new episode of
certified country next Friday
see you then